I'm going to get better It's
supposed to be a more difficult treatment than Silver-senpai's time
[Music]
What are you doing? Hey,
what are you
doing?  But
I'll get another one's arm as a
replacement Now,
who's going to give me your
arm to please me
?
Normally, MUJI's arms
are worthless, but it
seems interesting to see that proud face screaming.  It's
different from just the movement of mana, isn't it?
Several wavelengths are mixed. Let's
go with a familiar mouth.  It
's true that the
power surpassing that was activated It hurts to have my favorite maid costume torn, but it's a splendid move.
It's
not just mana, it's
similar, but it's using a higher power, is
n't it?  That's why,
if this evolves, it
might even catch up with the ether It's
wonderful But I
don't understand the power at all What is that power? Who the
hell is that power?  I wonder if it's okay for you to keep touching my chest.